(cris de la foule)éééééééééééééé
extirpé d'un puits tard samediie
la foule massée autour du site
de recherche.ététététététététété
en ambulance. Finalement,
la longue et délicate opération
de recherche n'a pas permis de
Tout a débuté mardi après-midis
un puits asséché de 32 mètres
d'un puits étroit, creusé près
de la résidence familiale dans
le secteur de Chefchaouen.
déroulée en plusieurs étapes.
Les équipes spécialisées ont
d'abord creusé le terrain
Par la suite, elles ont
poursuivi le forage d'un tunnel
horizontal pour atteindre
périlleux en raison du sol
friable.
Dans les  j j j j jours,
les secouristes lui avaient faie
l'eau,iriririririr s'ils avaient
atteint leur cible.rarararararae
un s s s s s similaire survenue
il y a trois ans en Espagne;dedé
orororororort après avoir chuté
dans un puits abandonné.erereret
éeéeéeéeéeées sur 13 jours